Dora is in McAllen Texas hi Dora how are
you just fine thank you
my question is regarding a purchase that
I made six months ago and I'm
questioning my sanity I'm not sure if I
made the right move or not I purchased
an efficiency in a restored area
I paid ninety five thousand for it I
paid cash for it I live about 80 miles
away from this efficiency 80 maybe 80
miles away yes I do own my home and so I
travel back and forth between my home in
this resort area on the weekend oh it's
a resort area yes we sort area okay it's
a small efficiency and it's 95 and I
paid ninety five thousand for it and I
guess my question is every once in a
while I panic and I'm thinking I should
have not bought this piece of real
estate it may be done something else for
the money okay how much other money do
you have I have well I own my home so
between money you have about seven
hundred and ten thousand in addition to
your home in an edition of the
efficiency yes sir okay and do you work
I am retired I bring home net pay of
about six to six thousand a year and you
live on that pretty easily
I live on about thirty five thousand
farms saving sometimes from here it's up
to thirty thousand a year
and you have seven hundred thousand
dollars in your nest egg yes and you're
how old six feet okay was the efficiency
a good buy in terms of price in terms of
price it is it's got a gorgeous view I
don't know what I asked what I asked was
is is it the value of the efficiency
more or less than 95 um I think it's
more okay all right so you didn't get
ripped off you didn't pay 95 for
something that's worth sixty oh no no
good most are running for about 112
hundred what when you bought it what was
your thinking what your thinking this is
like a dream come true I get to be on
the beach and I've always wanted to do
that or is that what was running through
your head well let me tell you what was
right I looked at it for about a year I
looked around and shop for about a year
I lost my husband two and a half years
ago we were big time travelers after he
passed away I tried traveling and I
really had a hard time I just didn't
enjoy as much I just didn't enjoy the
travel well I thought well I still want
to get away from my home I still want to
be in a restored area and I don't like
the packing and I'm packing on the
weekends so that was my reasoning for
that but the resort area the resort area
you went to I mean is it a beach is that
what it is yes okay and so you enjoy the
beach yeah okay and so you like
everything about the efficiency and the
whole deal the only thing you're worried
about is the money parts keeping you up
at night yes if the money part wasn't
there yet the whole idea is a great idea
still yes okay all right here's my
opinion Dora you need to calm down and
enjoy your money you didn't do it dad
blame thing wrong this was a great Buy
I'm glad you bought it you and your
husband worked your whole lives you've
got a million dollar net worth you spent
10% of it on your resort vacation
getaway beach thingy that you're
enjoying and you earned the money to do
it and I want you to take a chill pill
and enjoy it well it's good to hear that
you know that's a widow I question every
move I made I want you calm down you're
smarter than you act like you are you're
smarter than you think you are thank you
you studied this you thought about it
you prayed about it
you made a good buy you didn't get
ripped off you bought something that was
consistent with your your goal and your
dream to have a place to chill on the
beach and you liked all of that
everything about this story is good and
right thank you okay enjoy your enjoy
your condo kiddo if you need anything
else you call
anytime ok thank you so much for your
time thank you if you live like no one
else later you're supposed to live and
give like no one else
don't let situations or people make you
feel guilty for enjoying your money
while you're being generous and while
you're investing Dora is very
conservative she's a millionaire and she
lives on $35,000 a year that y'all hear
those numbers that was their numbers
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else and
that's right where she is you're
supposed to enjoy your money I refuse to
feel guilty or bad for being successful
I refuse I'm not gonna let any of you
liberals talk me into being guilty or
feel shamed for having won I went out
and I played the game fair I helped a
bunch of people Dora went out she and
her husband went out played the game
fair guy I talked to yesterday there's
63 years old who's been investing in his
401 K for 35 years and he had 2.9
million dollars in and he's getting
ready to buy a $300,000 house same
question he was wondering if he should
had done something wrong I refused to
let you people in this culture that are
toxic and your brains are twisted out of
your little tiny heads tell everybody
that's winning that you're not supposed
to enjoy winning you're supposed to
enjoy it you're not supposed to be mean
about it or overbearing about it but I
drove a piece-of-crap car I no longer do
I drove a car that the predominant color
on it was bondo I paid a price
I drove like no one else now I've got a
couple of nice cars and I'm going to
enjoy them and if you don't like
change the channel you got the wrong guy
to talk to you cuz this guy is the guy
who believes in the American dream and I
believe part of the American dream is
building wealth and you haven't done
anything wrong and that's not greedy and
you haven't harmed someone and you're
small-minded little twerps that think
otherwise need to move on with your
lives because you take someone like
adora and make her think she's done
something wrong and she's sitting in
fretting and wondering if she should
enjoy the money that she's worked her
whole freakin life for because somehow
some of you have gotten your backward
buttheads that she did something wrong
well that's what it is it's a backward
but ahead know what that looks like
that'd be interesting hey I'm not gonna
apologize for winning anymore
I'm not gonna be mean about it I'm not
gonna rub your nose in it I'm gonna help
you wherever you are but I'm not gonna
apologize for winning this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you
you